-- week of 6.046.
Woohoo!
The topic of this final week,
among our advanced topics,
is cache oblivious algorithms.
This is a particularly fun
area, one dear to my heart
because I've done a lot of
research in this area.
This is an area co-founded by
Professor Leiserson.
So, in fact,
the first context in which I
met Professor Leiserson was him
giving a talk about cache
oblivious algorithms at WADS '99
in Vancouver I think.
Yeah, that has to be an odd
year.
So, I learned about cache
oblivious algorithms then,
started working in the area,
and it's been a fun place to
play.
But this topic in some sense
was also developed in the
context of this class.
I think there was one semester,
probably also '98-'99 where all
of the problem sets were about
cache oblivious algorithms.
And they were,
in particular,
working out the research ideas
at the same time.
So, it must have been fun
semester.
We consider doing that this
semester, but we kept it to the
simple.
We know a lot more about cache
oblivious algorithms by now as
you might expect.
Right, I think that's all the
setting.
I mean, it was kind of
developed also with a bunch of
MIT students in particular,
M.Eng.
student, Harold Prokop.
It was his M.Eng.
thesis.
There is all the citations I
will give for now.
I haven't posted yet,
but there are some lecture
notes that are already on my
webpage.
But I will link to them from
the course website that gives
all the references for all the
results I'll be talking about.
They've all been done in the
last five years or so,
in particular,
starting in '99 when the first
paper was published.
But I won't give the specific
citations in lecture.
And, this topic is related to
the topic of last week,
multithreaded algorithms,
although at a somewhat high
level.
And then it's also dealing with
parallelism in modern machines.
And we've had throughout all of
these last two lectures,
we've had this very simple
model of a computer where we
have random access.
You can access memory at a cost
of one.
You can read and write a word
of memory.
There is some details on how
big a word can be and whatnot.
It's pretty basic,
simple, flat model.
And, at the multithreaded
algorithm is the idea that,
well, maybe you have multiple
threads of computation running
at once, but you still have this
very flat memory.
Everyone can access anything in
memory at a constant cost.
We're going to change that
model now.
And we are going to realize
that a real machine,
the memory of a real machine is
some hierarchy.
You have some CPU,
you have some cache,
probably on the same chip,
level 1 cache,
you have some level 2 cache,
if you're lucky,
maybe you have some level 3
cache, before you get to main
memory.
And then, you probably have a
really big disk and probably
there's even some cache out
here, but I won't even think
about that.
So, the point is,
you have lots of different
levels of memory and what's
changing here is that things
that are very close to the CPU
are very fast to access.
Usually level 1 cache you can
access in one clock cycle or a
few.
And then, things get slower and
slower.
Memory still costs like 70 ns
or so to access a chunk out of.
And that's a long time.
70 ns is, of course,
a very long time.
So, as we go out here,
we get slower.
But we also get bigger.
I mean, if we could put
everything at level 1 cache,
the problem would be solved.
But what would be a flat
memory.
Accessing everything in here,
we assumed takes the same
amount of time.
But usually,
we can't afford,
it's not even possible to put
everything in level 1 cache.
I mean, there's a reason why
there is a memory hierarchy.
Does anyone have a suggestion
on what that reason might be?
It's like one of these limits
in life.
Yeah?
Fast memory is expensive.
That's the practical
limitations indeed,
that you could try to build
more and more at level 1 cache
and maybe you could try to,
well, yeah.
Expenses is a good reason,
and practically,
that's why they may be the
sizes are what they are.
But suppose really fast memory
were really cheap.
There is a physical limitation
of what's going on,
yeah?
The speed of light.
Yeah, that's a bit of a
problem, right?
No matter how much,
let's suppose you can only fit
so many bits in an atom.
You can only fit so many bits
in a particular amount of space.
If you want more bits,
and you need more space,
and the more space you have,
the longer it's going to take
for a round-trip.
So, if you assume your CPU is
like this point in space,
so it's relatively small and it
has to get the data in,
the bigger the data,
the farther it has to be away.
But, you can have these cores
around the CPU that are,
we don't usually live in 3-D,
and chips were usually in 2-D,
but never mind.
You can have the sphere that's
closer to the CPU that's a lot
faster to access.
And as you get further away it
costs more.
And that's essentially what
this model is representing,
although it's a bit
approximated from the intrinsic
physics and geometry and
whatnot.
But that's the idea.
The latency,
the round-trip time to get some
of this memory has to be big.
In general, the costs to access
memory is made up of two things.
There's the latency,
the round-trip time,
which in particular is limited
by the speed of light.
And, plus the round-trip time,
you also have to get the data
out.
And depending on how much data
you want, it could take longer.
OK, so there's something.
There could be,
get this right,
let's say, the amount of data
divided by the bandwidth.
OK, the bandwidth is at what
rate can you get the data out?
And if you look at the
bandwidth of these various
levels of memory,
it's all pretty much the same.
If you have a well-designed
computer the bandwidths should
all be the same.
OK, as you can still get data
off disc really,
really fast,
usually at about the speed of
your bus, and that the bus gets
the CPU hopefully as fast as
everything else.
So, even though they're slower,
they're really only slower in
terms of latency.
And so, this part is maybe
reasonable.
The bandwidth looks pretty much
the same universally.
It's the latency that's going
up.
So, if the latency is going up
but we still get to divide by
the same amount of bandwidth,
what should we do to make the
access cost at all these levels
about the same?
This is fixed.
Let's say this is increasing,
but this is still staying big.
What could we do to balance
this formula?
Change the amounts.
As the latency goes up,
if we increase the amount,
then the amortized cost to
access one element will go down.
So, this is amortization in a
very simple sense.
So, this was to access a whole
block, let's say,
and this amount was the size of
the block.
So, the amortized cost,
then, to access one element is
going to be the latency divided
by the size of the block,
the amount plus one over the
bandwidth.
OK, so this is what you should
implicitly be thinking in your
head.
So, I'm just dividing here by
the amounts because the amount
is how many elements you get in
one access, let's suppose.
OK, so we get this formula for
the amortized cost.
The one over bandwidth is going
to be good no matter what level
we are on, I claim.
There's no real fundamental
limitation there except it might
be expensive.
And the latency week at the
amortized out by the amounts,
so whatever the latency is,
at the latency gets bigger out
here, we just get more and more
stuff and then we make these two
terms equal, let's say.
That would be a good way to
balance things.
So what particular,
disc has a really high latency.
Not only is there speed of
light issues here,
but there's actually the speed
of the head moving on the tracks
of the disk.
That takes a long time.
There's a physical motion.
Everything else here doesn't
usually have physical motion.
It's just electric.
So, this is really,
really slow and latency,
so when you read something out
of disk, you might as well read
a lot of data from disc,
like a megabyte or so.
It's probably even old these
days.
Maybe you read multiple
megabytes when you read anything
from disk if you want these to
be matched.
OK, there's a bit of a problem
with doing that.
Any suggestions what the
problem would be?
So, you have this algorithm.
And, whenever it reads
something off of desk,
it reads an entire megabyte of
stuff around the element it
asked for.
So the amortized cost to access
is going to be reasonable,
but that's actually sort of
assuming something.
Yeah?
Right.
I'm assuming I'm ever going to
use the rest of that data.
If I'm going to read 10 MB
around the one element that
asked for, I access A bracket I,
and I get 10 million items from
A around I, it would be kind of
good if the algorithm actually
used that data for something.
It seems reasonable.
So, this would be spatial
locality.
So, we want,
I mean the goal of this world
in cache oblivious algorithms
and cache efficient algorithms
in general is you want
algorithms that perform well
when this is happening.
So, this is the idea of
blocking.
And we want the algorithm to
use all or at least most of the
elements in a block,
a consecutive chunk of memory.
So, this is spatial locality.
Ideally, we'd use all of them
right then.
But I mean, depending on your
algorithm, that's a little bit
tricky.
There is another issue,
though.
So, you read in your thing
into, read your 10 MB into main
memory, let's say,
and your memory,
let's say, is at least,
these days you should have a 4
GB memory or something.
So, you could read and actually
a lot of different blocks into
main memory.
What you'd like is that you can
use those blocks for as long as
possible.
Maybe you don't even use them.
If you have a linear time
algorithm, you're probably only
going to visit each element a
constant number of times.
So, this is enough.
But if your algorithm is more
than linear time,
you're going to be accessing
elements more than once.
So, it would be a good idea not
only to use all the elements of
the blocks, but use them as many
times as you can before you have
to throw the block out.
That's temporal locality.
So ideally, you even reuse
blocks as much as possible.
So, I mean, we have all these
caches.
So, I didn't write this word.
Just in case I don't know how
to spell it, it's not the money.
We should use those caches for
something.
I mean, the fact that they
store more than one block,
each cache can store several
blocks.
How many?
Well, we'll get to that in a
second.
OK, so this is the general
motivation, but at this point
the model is still pretty damn
ugly.
If you wanted to design an
algorithm that runs well on this
kind of machine directly,
it's possible but pretty
difficult, and essentially never
done, let's say,
even though this is what real
machines look like.
At least in theory,
and pretty much in practice,
the main thing to think about
is two levels at a time.
So, this is a simplification
where we can say a lot more
about algorithms,
a simplification over this
model.
So, in this model,
each of these levels has
different block sizes,
and a different total sizes,
it's a mess to deal with and
design algorithms for.
If you just think about two
levels, it's relatively easy.
So, we have our CPU which we
assume has a constant number of
registers only.
So, you know,
once it has a couple of data
items, you can add them and
whatnot.
Then we have this really fast
pipe.
So, I draw it thick to some
cache.
So this is cache.
And, we have a relatively
narrow pipe to some really big
other storage,
which I will call main memory.
So, I mean, that's the general
picture.
Now, this could represent any
two of these levels.
It could be between L3 cache
and make memory.
That's maybe,
what?
The naming corresponds to best.
Or cache could in fact be main
memory, what we consider the RAM
of the machine,
and what's called a memory over
there to be the disk.
It's whatever you care about.
And usually,
if you have a program,
that's what usually we assume
everything fits in main memory.
Then you care about the caching
behavior.
So you probably look between
these two levels.
That's probably what matters
the most inner program because
the cost differential here is
really big relative to the cost
differential here.
If your data doesn't even fit
it main memory,
and you have to go to disk,
then you really care about this
level because the cost
differential here is huge.
It's like six orders of
magnitude, let's say.
So, in practice you may think
of just two memory levels that
are the most relevant.
OK, now I'm going to define
some parameters.
I'm going to call them cache
and make memory just for clarity
because I like to think of main
memory just the way it used to
be.
And now all we have to worry
about is this extra thing called
cache.
It has some bounded size,
and there's a block size.
The block size is B.
and a number of blocks is M
over B.
So, the total size of the cache
is M.
OK, main memory is also blocked
into blocks of size B.
And we assume that it has
essentially infinite size.
We don't care about its size in
this picture.
It's whatever is big enough to
hold the size of your algorithm,
or data structure,
or whatever.
OK, so that's the general
model.
And for strange,
historical reasons,
which I don't want to get into,
these things are called capital
M and capital B.
Even though M sounds a lot like
memory, it's really for cache,
and don't ask.
OK, this is to preserve
history.
OK, now what do we do with this
model?
It seems nice,
but now what do we measure
about it?
What I'm going to assume is
that the cache is really fast.
So the CPU can access cache
essentially instantaneously.
I still have to pay for the
computation that the CPU is
doing, but I'm assuming cache is
close enough that I don't care.
And that may memory is so big
that it has to be far away,
and therefore,
this pipe is a problem.
I mean, what I should really
draw is that pipe is still
thick, but is really long.
So, the latency is high.
The bandwidth is still high.
OK, and all transfers here
happened as blocks.
So, when you don't have
something, so the idea is CPU
asks for A of I,
as for something in memory,
if it's in the cache,
it gets it.
That's free.
Otherwise, it has to grab the
entire block containing that
element from main memory,
brings it into cache,
maybe kicks somebody out if the
cache was full,
and then the CPU can use that
data and keep going.
Until it accesses something
else that's not in cache,
then it has to grab it from
main memory.
When you kick something out,
you're actually writing back to
memory.
That's the model.
So, we suppose the accesses to
cache are free.
But we can still think about
the running time of the
algorithm.
I'm not going to change the
definition of running time.
This would be the computation
time, or the work if you want to
use multithreaded lingo,
computation time.
OK, so we still have time,
and T of N will still mean what
it did before.
This is just an extra level of
refinement of understanding of
what's going on.
Essentially,
measuring the parallelism that
we can exploit out of the memory
system, that when you access
something you actually get B
items.
So, this is the old stuff.
Now, what I want to do is count
memory transfers.
These are transfers of blocks,
so I should say block memory
transfers between the two
levels, so, between the cache
and main memory.
So, memory transfers are either
reading reads or writes.
Maybe I should say that.
These are number of block reads
and writes from and to the main
memory.
OK, so I'm going to introduce
some notation.
This is new notation,
so we'll see how it works out.
MT of N I want to represent the
number of memory transfers
instead of just normal time of
the problem of size N.
Really, this is a function that
depends not only on N but also
on these parameters,
B and M, in our model.
So, this is what it should be,
MT_B,M(N), but that's obviously
pretty messy,
so I'm going to stick to MT of
N.
But this will always,
because mainly I care about the
growth in terms of N.
well, I care about the growth
in terms of all things,
but the only thing I could
change is N.
So, most of the time I only
think about, like when we are
writing recurrences,
only N is changing.
I can't recurse on the block
size.
I can't recurse on the size of
cache.
Those are given to me.
They're fixed.
OK, so we'll be changing N
mainly.
But B and M always matter here.
They're not constants.
They're parameters of the
model.
OK, easy enough.
This is something called the
disk access model,
if you like DAM models,
or the external memory model,
or the cache aware model.
Maybe I should mention that;
this is the cache aware.
In general, you have some
algorithm that runs on this kind
of model, machine model.
That's a cache aware algorithm.
OK, we're not too interested in
cache aware algorithms.
We've seen one,
B trees.
B trees are cache aware data
structure.
You assume that there is some
block size, B,
underlying.
Maybe you didn't see exactly
this model.
In particular,
it didn't really matter how big
the cache was because you just
wanted to know.
When I read B items,
I can use all of them as much
as possible and figure out where
I fit among those B items,
and that gives me log base B of
N memory transfers instead of
log N, which would be,
if you just threw your favorite
balanced binary search tree.
So, log base B of N is
definitely better than log base
2 of N.
B trees are a cache aware
algorithm.
OK, what we would like to do
today and next lecture is get
cache oblivious algorithms.
So, there's essentially only
one difference between cache
aware algorithms and cache
oblivious algorithms.
In cache oblivious algorithms,
the algorithm doesn't know what
B and M are.
So this is a bit of a subtle
point, but very cool idea.
You assume that this is the
model of the machine,
and you care about the number
of memory transfers between this
cache of size M with blocking B,
and main memory with blocking
B.
But you don't actually know
what the model is.
You don't know the other
parameters of the model.
It looks like this,
but you don't know the width.
You don't know the height.
Why not?
So, the analysis knows what B
and M are.
We are going to write some
algorithms which look just like
boring old algorithms that we've
seen throughout the lecture.
That's one of the nice things
about this model.
Every algorithm we have seen is
a cache oblivious algorithm,
all right, because we didn't
even know the word cache in this
class until today.
So, we already have lots of
algorithms to choose from.
The thing is,
some of them will perform well
in this model,
and some of them won't.
So, we would like to design
algorithms that just like our
old algorithms that happened to
perform well in this context,
no matter what B and M are.
So, another way this is the
same algorithm should work well
for all values of B and M if you
have a good cache oblivious
algorithm.
OK, there are a few
consequences to this assumption.
In a cache aware algorithm,
you can explicitly say,
OK, I'm blocking my memory into
chunks of size B.
Here they are.
I was going to store these B
elements here,
these B elements here,
because you know B,
you can do that.
You can say,
well, OK, now I want to read
these B items into my cache,
and then write out these ones
over here.
You can explicitly maintain
your cache.
With cache oblivious
algorithms, you can't because
you don't know what it is.
So, it's got to be all
implicit.
And this is pretty much how
caches work anyway except for
disk.
So, it's a pretty reasonable
model.
In particular,
when you access an element
that's not in cache,
you automatically fetch the
block containing that element.
And you pay one memory transfer
for that if it wasn't already
there.
Another bit of a catch here is,
what if your cache is full?
Then you've got to kick some
block out of your cache.
And then, so we need some model
of which block gets kicked out
because we can't control that.
We have no knowledge of what
the blocks are in our algorithm.
So what we're going to assume
in this model is the ideal
thing, that when you fetch a new
block, if your cache is full,
you evict a block that will be
used farthest in the future.
Sorry, the furthest.
Farthest is distance.
Furthest is time.
Furthest in the future.
OK, this would be the best
possible thing to do.
It's a little bit hard to do in
practice because you don't know
the future generally,
unless you're omniscient.
So, this is a bit of an
idealized model.
But it's pretty reasonable in
the sense that if you've read
the reading handout number 20,
this paper by Sleator and
Tarjan, they introduce the idea
of competitive algorithms.
So, we only talked about a
small portion of that paper that
moved to front heuristic for
storing a list.
But, it also proves that there
are strategies,
and maybe you heard this in
recitation.
Some people covered it;
some didn't,
that these are called paging
strategies.
So, you want to maintain some
cache of pages or blocks,
and you pay whenever you have
to access a block that's not in
your cache.
The best thing to do is to
always kick out the block that
will be used farthest in the
future because that way you'll
use all the blocks that are in
there.
This turns out to be the
offline optimal strategy if you
knew the future.
But, there are algorithms that
are essentially constant
competitive against this
strategy.
I don't want to get into
details because they're not
exactly constant competitive.
But they are sufficiently
constant competitive for the
purposes of this lecture that we
can assume this,
not have to worry about it.
Most of the time,
we don't even really use this
assumption.
But there it is.
That's the cache oblivious
model.
It makes things cleaner to
think about just anything that
should be done,
will be done.
And you can simulate that with
least recently used or whatever
good heuristic that you want to
that's competitive against the
optimal.
OK, that's pretty much the
cache oblivious algorithm.
Once you have the two level
model, you just assume you don't
know B and M.
You have this automatic request
in writing, and whatnot.
A little bit more to say,
I guess, it may be obvious at
this point, but I've been
drawing everything as tables.
So, it's not really clear what
the linear order is.
Linear order is just the
reading order.
So, although we don't
explicitly say it most of the
time, a typical model is that
memory is a linear array.
Everything that you ever store
in your program is written in
this linear array.
If you've ever programmed in
Assembly or whatever,
that's the model.
You have the address space,
and any number between here and
here, that's where you can
actually, this is physical
memory.
This is all you can write to.
So, it starts at zero and goes
out to, let's call it infinity
over here.
And, if you allocate some
array, maybe it occupies some
space in the middle.
Who knows?
OK, we usually don't think
about that much.
What I care about now is that
memory itself is blocked in this
view.
So, however your stuff is
stored in memory,
it's blocked into clusters of
length B.
So, if this is,
let me call it one and be a
little bit nicer.
This is B.
This is position B plus one.
This is 2B, and 2B plus one,
and so on.
These are the indexes into
memory.
This is how the blocking
happens.
If you access something here,
you get that chunk from U,
round it down to the previous
multiple of B,
round it up to the next
multiple of B.
That's what you always get.
OK, so if you think about some
array that's maybe allocated
here, OK, you have to keep in
mind that that array may not be
perfectly aligned with the
blocks.
But more or less it will be so
we don't care too much.
But that's a bit of a subtlety
there.
OK, so that's pretty much the
model.
So every algorithm we've seen,
except B trees,
is a cache oblivious algorithm.
And our question is,
now, we know how everything
runs in terms of running time.
Now we want to measure the
number of memory transfers,
MT of N.
I want to mention one other
fact or theorem.
I'll put it in brackets because
I don't want to state it
precisely.
But if you have an algorithm
that is efficient on two levels,
so in other words,
what we're looking at,
if we just think about the two
level world and your algorithm
is cache oblivious,
then it is efficient on any
number of levels in your memory
hierarchy, say,
L levels.
So, I don't want to define what
efficient means.
But the intuition is,
if your machine really looks
like this and you have a cache
oblivious algorithm,
you can apply the cache
oblivious analysis for all B and
M.
So you can analyze the number
of memory transfers here,
here, here, here,
and here.
And if you have a good cache
oblivious algorithm,
the performances at all those
levels has to be good.
And therefore,
the whole performance is good.
Good here means asymptotically
optimal up to constant factors,
something like that.
OK, so I don't want to prove
that, and you can read the cache
oblivious papers.
That's a nice fact about cache
oblivious algorithms.
If you have a cache aware
algorithm that tunes to a
particular value of B,
and a particular value of M,
you're not going to have that
problem.
So, this is one nice feature of
cache obliviousness.
Another nice feature is when
you are coding the algorithm,
you don't have to put in B and
M.
So, that simplifies things a
bit.
So, let's do some algorithms.
Enough about models.
OK, we're going to start out
with some really simple things
just to get warmed up on the
analysis side.
The most basic thing you can do
that's good in a cache oblivious
world is scanning.
So, scanning is just visiting
the items in an array in order.
So, visit A_1 up to A_N in
order.
For some notion of visit,
this is presumably some
constant time operation.
For example,
suppose you want to compute the
aggregate of the array.
You want to sum all the
elements in the array.
So, you have one extra variable
using, but you can store that in
a register or whatever,
so that's one simple example.
Sum the array.
OK, so here's the picture.
We have our memory.
Each of these cells represents
one item, one element,
log N bits, one word,
whatever.
Our array is somewhere in here.
Maybe it's there.
And we go from here to here to
here to here.
OK, and so on.
So, what does this cost?
What is the number of memory
transfers?
We know that this is a linear
time algorithm.
It takes order N time.
What does it cost in terms of
memory transfers?
N over B, pretty much.
We like to say it's order N
over B plus two or one in the
big O.
This is a bit of worry.
I mean, N could be smaller than
B.
We really want to think about
all the cases,
especially because usually
you're not doing this on
something of size N.
You're doing it on something of
size k, where we don't really
know much about k.
But in general,
it's N over B plus one because
we always need at least one
memory transfer to look at
something, unless N is zero.
And in particular,
it's plus two if you care about
the constants.
If I don't write the big O,
then it would be plus two at
most because you could
essentially waste the first
block and that everything is
fine for awhile.
And then, if you're unlucky,
you essentially waste the last
blocked.
There is just one element in
that block, and you're not
getting much out of it.
Everything in the middle,
though, every block between the
first and last block has to be
full.
So, you're using all of those
elements.
So out of the N elements,
you only have N over B blocks
because the block has B
elements.
OK, that's pretty trivial.
Let me do something slightly
more interesting,
which is two scans at once.
OK, here we are not assuming
anything about M.
we're not assuming anything
about the size of the cache,
just that I can hold a single
block.
The last block that we visited
has to be there.
OK, you can also do a constant
number of parallel scans.
This is not really parallel in
the sense of multithreaded,
bit simulated parallelism.
I mean, if you have a constant
number, do one,
do the other,
come back, come back,
come back, all right,
visit them in turn round robin,
whatever.
For example,
here's a cute piece of code.
If you want to reverse an
array, OK, then you can do it.
This is a good puzzle.
You can do it by essentially
two scans where you repeatedly
swapped the first and last
element.
So I was swapping A_i with N
minus i plus one,
and just restart at one.
So, here's your array.
Suppose this is actually my
array.
I swap these two guys,
and I saw these two guys,
and so on.
That will reverse my array,
and this should work hopefully
the middle as well if it's odd.
It should not do anything.
And you can view this as two
scans.
There is one scan that's coming
in this way.
There's also a reverse scan,
ooh, some more sophisticated,
coming back this way.
Of course, reverse scan has the
same analysis.
And as long as your cache is
big enough to store at least two
blocks, which is a pretty
reasonable assumption,
so let's write it.
Assuming the number of blocks
in the cache,
which is M over B,
is at least two in this
algorithm, the number of memory
transfers is still order N over
B plus one.
OK, the constant goes up maybe,
but in this case it probably
doesn't.
But who cares.
OK, as long as you're doing a
constant number of scans,
and some constant number of
arrays, it happens to be one of
them's reversed,
whatever, it will take,
we call this linear time.
It's linear in the number of
blocks in your input.
OK, great.
So now you can reverse an
array: exciting.
Let's try another simple
algorithm on another board.
Let's try binary search.
So just like last week,
we're going back to our basics
here.
Scanning we didn't even talk
about in this class.
Binary search is something we
talked about a little bit.
It was a simple divide and
conquer algorithm.
I hope you all remember it.
And if we look at an array,
and I'm not going to draw the
cells here because I want to
imagine a really big array,
binary search,
but suppose it always goes to
left.
It starts by visiting this
element in the middle.
Then ago so the quarter marked.
Then it goes to the one eighth
mark.
OK, this is one hypothetical
execution of a binary search.
OK, and eventually it finds the
element it's looking for.
It finds where it fits at
least.
So x is over here.
So, we know that it takes log N
time.
How many memory transfers of
the take?
Now, I blocked this array into
chunks of size B,
blocks of size B.
How many blocks do I touch?
This one's a little bit more
subtle.
It depends on the relative
sizes of N and B,
yeah.
Log base B of N would be a good
guess.
We would like it to be,
let's say, hope,
is that it's log base B of N
because we know that B trees can
search in what's essentially a
sorted list of N items in log
base B of N time.
That turns out to be optimal in
the cache oblivious model or in
the two level model you've got
to pay log base B of N.
I won't prove that here.
The same reason you need log N
comparisons to do a binary
search in the normal model.
Alas, it is possible to get log
base B of N even without knowing
B.
But, binary search does not do
it.
Log of N over B,
yes.
So the number of memory
transfers on N items is log of N
over B also known as,
let's say, plus one,
also known as log N minus log
B.
OK, whereas log base B of N is
log N divided by log B,
OK, clearly this is much better
than subtracting.
So, this would be good,
but this is bad.
Most of the time,
this is log N,
which is no better,
I mean, you're not using blocks
at all essentially.
The idea is,
out here, I mean,
there's some little,
tiny block that contains this
thing.
I mean, tiny depends on how big
B is.
But, each of these items will
be in a different block until
you get essentially within one
block worth of x.
When you get within one block
worth of x, there's only like a
constant number of blocks that
matter, and so all of these
accesses are indeed within the
same block.
But, how many are there?
Well, just log B because you're
only spending log B within a,
if you're within an interval of
size k, you're only going to
spend log k steps in it.
So, you're saving log B in
here, but overall you're paying
log N, so you only get log N
minus log B plus some constant.
OK, so this is bad news for
binary search.
So, not all of the algorithms
we've seen are going to work
well in this model.
We need a lot more thinking
before we can solve what is
essentially the binary search
problem, finding an element in a
sorted list, in log base B of N
without knowing B.
OK, we know we could use B
trees.
If you knew B,
great, that works,
and that's optimal.
But without knowing B,
it's a little bit harder.
And this gets us into the world
of divide and conquer.
Also like last week,
and like the first few weeks of
this class, divide and conquer
is your friend.
And, it turns out divide and
conquer is not the only tool,
but it's a really useful tool
in designing cache oblivious
algorithms.
And, let me say why.
So, we'll see a bunch of divide
and conquer based algorithms,
cache oblivious.
And, the intuition is that we
can take all the favorite
algorithms we have,
obviously it doesn't always
work.
Binary search was a divide and
conquer algorithm.
It's not so great.
But, in general,
the idea is that your algorithm
can just do the normal divide
and conquer thing,
right?
You divide your problem into
subproblems of smaller size
repeatedly, all the way down to
problems of constant size,
OK, just like before.
But, if you're recursively
dividing your problem into
smaller things,
at some point you can think
about it and say,
well, wait, I mean,
the algorithm divides all the
way, but we can think about the
point at which the problem fits
in a block or fits in cache.
OK, and that's the analysis.
OK, we'll think about the time
when your problem is small
enough that we can analyze it in
some other way.
So, usually,
we analyze it recursively.
We get a recurrence.
What we're changing,
essentially,
is the base case.
So, in the base case,
we don't want to go down to a
constant size.
That's too far.
I'll show you some examples.
We want to consider the point
in recursion at which either the
problem fits in cache,
so it has size less than or
equal to M, or it fits in order
one blocks.
That's another natural time to
do it.
Order one blocks would be even
better than fitting in cache.
So, this means a size order B.
OK, this will change the base
case of the recurrence,
and it will turn out to give us
good answers instead of bad
ones.
So, let's do a simple example.
Our good friend order
statistics, in particular,
for finding medians.
So, I hope you all know this by
heart.
Remember the worst case linear
time, median finding algorithm
by Bloom et al.
I'll write this fast.
We partition our array.
It turns out,
this is a good algorithm as it
is.
We partition our array
conceptually into N over five,
five tuples into little groups
of five.
This may not have been exactly
how I wrote it last time.
I didn't check.
But, it's the same algorithm.
You compute the median of each
five tuple.
Then you recursively compute
the median of the medians of
these medians.
Then, you partition around x.
So, that gave us some element
that was roughly in the middle.
It was within the middle half,
I think.
Partition around x,
and then we show that you could
always recurse on just one of
the sides.
OK, this was our good old
friend for computing,
order statistics,
or medians, or whatnot.
OK, so how much time does this,
well, we know how much time
this takes.
It should be linear time.
But how many memory transfers
does this take?
Well, conceptually partitioning
that, I can do,
in zero.
Maybe I have to compute N over
five, no big deal here.
We're not thinking about
computation.
I have to find the median of
each tuple.
So, here it matters how my
array is laid out.
But, what I'm going to do is
take my array,
take the first five elements,
and then the next five elements
and so on.
Those will be my five tuples.
So, I can implement this just
by scanning, and then computing
the median on those five
elements, which I stored in the
five registers on my CPU.
I'll assume that there are
enough registers for that.
And, I compute the median,
write it out to some array out
here.
So, it's going to be one
element.
So, the median of here goes
into there.
The median of these guys goes
into there, and so on.
So, I'm scanning in here,
and in parallel,
I'm scanning an output in here.
So, it's two parallel scans.
So, that takes linear time.
So, this takes order N over B
plus one memory transfers.
OK, then we have recursively
compute the median of the
medians.
This step used to be T of N
over five.
Now it's MT of N over five,
OK, with the same values of B
and M.
Then we partition around x.
Partitioning is also like three
parallel scans if you work it
out.
So, this is also going to take
linear memory transfers,
N over B plus one.
And then, we recurse on one of
the sides, and this is the fun
part of the analysis which I
won't repeat here.
But, we get MT of,
like, three quarters N.
I think originally it was seven
tenths, so we simplified to
three quarters,
which is hopefully bigger than
seven tenths.
Yeah, it is.
OK, so this is the new
analysis.
Now we get a recurrence.
So, let's do that.
So, the analysis is we get this
MT of N is MT of N over five
plus MT of three quarters N
plus, this is just as before.
Before we had linear work here.
And now, we have what we call
linear number of memory
transfers, linear number of
blocks.
OK, I'll sort of ignore this
plus one.
It's not too critical.
So, this is our recurrence.
Now, it depends what our base
case is.
And, usually we would use a
base case of constant size.
So, let's see what happens if
we use a base case of constant
size just so that it's clear why
this base case is so important.
OK, this describes a recurrence
as one of these hairy
recurrences.
And, I don't want to use
substitution.
I just want the intuition of
why this is going to solve to
something rather big.
OK, and for me,
the best intuition always comes
from recursion trees.
If you don't know the solution
to recurrence and you need a
good guess, use recursion trees.
And today, I will only give you
good guesses.
I don't want to prove anything
with substitution because I want
to get to the bigger ideas.
So, this is even messy from a
recursion tree point of view
because you have these
unbalanced sizes where you start
at the root with some of size N
over B.
Then you split it into
something size one fifth N over
B, and something of size three
quarters N over B,
which is annoying because now
this subtree will be a lot
bigger than this one,
or this one will terminate
faster.
So, it's pretty unbalanced.
But, summing per level doesn't
really tell you a lot at this
point.
But let's just look at the
bottom level.
Look at all the leaves in this
recursion tree.
So, that's the base cases.
How many base cases are there?
This is an interesting
question.
We've never thought about it in
the context of this recurrence.
It gives a somewhat surprising
answer.
It was surprising to me the
first time I worked it out.
So, how many leaves does this
recursion tree have?
Well, we can write a
recurrence.
The number of leaves in a
problem of size N,
it's going to be the number of
leaves in this problem plus the
number of leaves in this problem
plus zero.
So, that's another recurrence.
We'll call this L of N.
OK, now the base case is really
relevant.
It determines the solution to
this recurrence.
And let's, again,
assume that in a problem of
size one, we have one leaf.
That's our only base case.
Well, it turns out,
and here you need to guess,
I think.
This is not particularly
obvious.
Any of the TA's have guesses of
the form of this solution?
Or anybody, not just TA's.
But this is open to everyone.
If Charles were here,
I would ask him.
I had to think for a while,
and it's not linear,
right, because you're somehow
decreasing quite a bit.
So, it's smaller than linear,
but it's more than a constant.
OK, it's actually more than
polylog, so what's your favorite
function in the middle?
N over log N,
that's still too big.
Keep going.
You have an oracle here,
so you can, N to the k,
yeah, close.
I mean, k is usually an
integer.
N to the alpha for some real
number between zero and one.
Yeah, that's what you meant.
Sorry.
It's like the shortest
mathematical joke.
Let epsilon be less than zero
or for a sufficiently large
epsilon.
I don't know.
So, you've got to use the right
letters.
So, let's suppose that it's N
to the alpha.
Then we would get this N over
five to the alpha,
and we'd get three quarters N
to the alpha.
When you have a nice recurrence
like this, you can just try
plugging in a guess and see
whether it works,
OK, and of course this will
work only depending on alpha.
So, we should get an equation
on alpha here.
So, everything has an N to the
alpha, in fact,
all of these terms.
So, I can divide through my N
to the alpha.
That's assuming that it's not
zero or something.
That seems reasonable.
So, we have one equals one
fifth to the alpha plus three
quarters to the alpha.
This is something you won't get
on a final because I don't know
any good way to solve this
except with like Maple or
Mathematica.
If you're smart I'm sure you
could compute it in a nicer way,
but alpha is about 0.8,
it turns out.
So, the number of leaves is
this sort of in between constant
and linear.
Usually polynomial means you
have an integer power.
Let's call it a polynomial.
Why not?
There's a lot of leaves,
is the point,
and if we say that each leaf
costs a constant number of
memory transfers,
we're in trouble because then
the number of memory transfers
has to be at least this.
If it's at least that,
that's potentially bigger than
N over B, I mean,
bigger than in an asymptotic
sense.
This is little omega of N over
B if B is big.
If B is at least N to the 0.2
something, OK,
or one seventh something.
But if, in particular,
B is at least N to the 0.2,
then this should be bigger than
that.
So, this is a bad analysis
because we're not going to get
the answer we want,
which is N over B.
The best you can do for median
is N over B because you have to
read all the element,
and you should spend linear
time.
So, we want to get N over B.
This algorithm is N over B plus
one.
So, this is why you need a good
base case, all right?
So that makes the point.
So, the question is,
what base case should I use?
So, we have this recurrence
What base case should I use?
Constant was too small.
We have a couple of choices
listed up here.
Any suggestions?
B, OK, MT of B is?
The hard part.
So, if my problem,
if the size of my array fits in
a block and I do all this stuff
on it, how many memory transfers
could that take?
One, or a constant,
depending on alignment.
OK, maybe it takes two memory
transfers, but constant.
Good.
That's clearly a lot better
than this base case,
MT of one equals order one,
clearly stronger.
So, hopefully,
it gives the right answer,
and now indeed it does.
I love this analysis.
So, I'm going to wave my hands.
OK, but in particular,
what this gives us,
if we do the previous analysis,
what is the number of leaves?
So, in the leaves,
now L of B equals one instead
of L of one equals one.
So, this stops earlier.
When does it stop?
Well, instead of getting N to
the order of 0.8,
whatever, we get N over B to
the power of 0.8 whatever.
OK, so it turns out the number
of leaves is N over B to the
alpha, which is little o of N
over B.
So, we don't care.
It's tiny.
And, if you look at the root
cost is N over B in the
recursion tree,
the leaf cost is little o of N
over B, and if you wave your
hands, and close your eyes,
and squint, the cost should be
geometrically decreasing as we
go down, I hope,
more or less.
It's a bit messy because of all
the things terminating,
but let's say cost is roughly
geometric.
Don't do this in the final,
but you won't have any messy
recurrences like this.
So, don't worry.
Down the tree,
so you'd have to prove this
formally, but I claim that the
root cost dominates.
And, the root cost is N over B.
So, we get N over B.
OK, so this is a nice,
linear time algorithm for order
statistics for cache oblivious.
Great.
This may turn you off a little
bit, but even though this is
like the simplest algorithm,
it's also probably the most
complicated analysis that we
will do.
In the future,
our algorithms will be more
complicated, and the analyses
will be relatively simple.
And usually,
it's that way with cache
oblivious algorithms.
So, I'm giving you this sort of
as the intuition of why this
should be enough.
Then you have to prove it.
OK, let's go to another problem
where divide and conquer is
useful, our good friend,
matrix multiplication.
I don't know how many times
we've seen this in this class,
but in particular we saw it
last week with a recursive
matrix multiply,
multithreaded algorithm.
So, I won't give you the
algorithm yet again,
but we're going to analyze it
in a very different way.
So, we have C and we have A,
and actually up to you.
So, I could cover standard
matrix multiplication,
which is when you do it row by
row, and column by column.
And, we could see why that's
bad.
And then, we could do the
recursive one and see why that's
good.
Or, we could skip the standard
algorithm.
So, how many people would like
to see why the standard
algorithm is bad?
Because it's not totally
obvious.
One, two, three,
four, five, half?
Wow, that's a lot of votes.
Now, how many people want to
skip to the chase?
No one.
One, OK.
And, everyone else is asleep.
So, that's pretty good,
50% awake, not bad.
OK, then, so standard matrix
multiplication.
I'll do this fast because it
is, I mean, you all know the
algorithm, right?
To compute this value of C;
in A, you take this row,
and in B you take this column.
Sorry I did a little bit
sloppily.
But this is supposed to be
aligned.
Right?
So I take all of this stuff,
I multiply it with all of the
stuff, add them up,
the dot product.
That gives me this element.
And, let's say I do them in
this order row by row.
So for every item in C,
I loop over this row and this
column, B, multiply them
together.
That is an access pattern in
memory.
So, exactly how much that costs
depends how these matrices are
laid out in memory.
OK, this is a subtlety we
haven't had to worry about
before because everything was
uniform.
I'm going to assume to give the
standard algorithm the best
chances of being good,
I'm going to store C in row
major order, A in row major
order, and B in column major
order.
So, everything is nice and
you're scanning.
So then this inner product is a
scan.
Cool.
Sounds great,
doesn't it?
It's bad, though.
Assume A is row major,
and B is column major.
And C, you could assume is
really either way,
but if I'm doing it row by row,
I'll assume it's row major.
So, this is what I call the
layout, the memory layout,
of these matrices.
OK, it's good for this
algorithm, but the algorithm is
not good.
So, it won't be that great.
So, how long does this take?
How many memory transfers?
We know it takes M^3 time.
Not going to try and beat M^3
here.
Just going to try and get
standard matrix multiplication
going faster.
So, well, for each item over
here I pay N over B to do the
scans and get the inner product.
So, N over B per item.
So, it's N over B,
or we could go with the plus
one here, to compute each c_ij.
So that would suggest,
as an upper bound at least,
it's N^3 over B.
OK, and indeed that is the
right bound, so theta.
This is memory transfers,
not time, obviously.
That is indeed the case because
if you look at consecutive,
I do this c_ij,
then this one,
this one, this one,
this one, keep incrementing j
and keeping I fixed,
right?
So, the row that I use stays
fixed for a long time.
I get to reuse that if it
happens, say that that fits a
block maybe, I get to reuse that
row several times if that
happens to fit in cache.
But the column is changing
every single time.
OK, so every time I moved here
and compute the next c_ij,
even if a column could fit in
cache, I can't fit all the
columns in cache.
And the columns that I'm
visiting move,
you know, they just scan
across.
So, I'm scanning this whole
matrix every time.
And unless you're entire matrix
fits in cache,
in which case you could do
anything, I don't care,
it will take constant time,
or you'll take M over B time,
enough to read it into the
cache, do your stuff,
and write it back out.
Except in that boring case,
you're going to have to pay N^2
over B for every row here
because you have to scan the
whole collection of columns.
You have to read this entire
matrix for every row over here.
So, you really do need N^3 over
B for the whole thing.
So, it's usually a theta.
So, you might say,
well, that's great.
It's the size of my problem,
the usual running time,
divided by B.
And that was the case when we
are thinking about linear time,
N versus N over B.
It's hard to beat N over B when
your problem is of size N.
But now we have a cubed.
And, this gets back to,
we have good spatial locality.
When we read a block,
we use the whole thing.
Great.
It seems optimal.
But we don't have good temporal
locality.
It could be that maybe if we
stored the right things,
we kept them around,
we could them several times
because we're using each element
like a cubed number of times.
That's not the right way of
saying it, but we're reusing the
matrices a lot,
reusing those items.
If we are doing N^3 work on N^2
things, we're reusing a lot.
So, we want to do better than
this, and that's the recursive
algorithm, which we've seen.
So, we know the algorithm
pretty much.
I just have to tell you what
the layout is.
So, we're going to take C,
partition of C_1-1,
C_1-2, and so on.
So, I have an N by N matrix,
and I'm partitioning into N
over 2 by N over 2 submatrices,
all three of them times
whatever.
And, I could write this out yet
again but I won't.
OK, we can recursively compute
this thing with eight matrix
multiplies, and a bunch of
matrix additions.
I don't care how many,
but a constant number.
We see that at least twice now,
so I won't show it again.
Now, how do I lay out the
matrices?
Any suggestions how I lay out
the matrices?
I could lay them out in row
major order.
I'll call it major order.
But that might be less natural
now.
We're not doing anything by
rows or by columns.
So, what layout should I use?
Yeah?
Quartet major order,
maybe quadrant major order
unless you're musically
inclined, yeah.
Good idea.
You've never seen this order
before, so it's maybe not so
natural.
Somehow I want to cluster it by
blocks.
OK, I think that's about all.
So, I mean, it's a recursive
layout.
This was not an easy question.
It's OK.
Store matrices or lay out the
matrices recursively by block.
OK, I'm cheating a little bit.
I'm redefining the problem to
say, assume that your matrices
are laid out in this way.
But, it doesn't really matter.
We can cheat,
can't we?
In fact, it doesn't matter.
You can turn a matrix into this
layout without too much linear
work, almost linear work.
Log factors,
maybe.
OK, so if I want to store my
matrix A as a linear thing,
I'm going to recursively
defined that layout to be
recursively store the upper left
corner, then store,
let's say, the upper right
corner.
It doesn't matter which order I
do these.
I should have drawn this wider,
then store the lower left
corner, and then store the lower
right corner recursively.
So, how do you store this?
Well, you divide it in four,
and lay out the top left,
and so on.
OK, this is a recursive
definition of how the element
should be stored in a linear
array.
It's a weird one,
but this is a very powerful
idea in cache oblivious
algorithms.
We'll use this multiple times.
OK, so now all we have to do is
analyze the number of memory
transfers.
How hard could it be?
So, we're going to store all
the matrices in this order,
and we want to compute the
number of memory transfers on an
N by N matrix.
See, I lapsed and I switched to
lowercase n.
I should, throughout this week,
be using uppercase N because
for historical reasons,
any external memory kinds of
algorithms, to level algorithms,
always talk about capital N.
And, don't ask why.
You should see what they define
little n to be.
OK, so, any suggestions on what
the recurrence should be now?
All his fancy setup with the
recurrence is actually pretty
easy.
So, definitely it involves
multiplying matrices that are N
over 2 by N over 2.
So, what goes here?
Eight, thank you.
That you should know.
And that the tricky part is
what goes here.
OK, what goes here is,
now, the fact that I can even
write this, this is the matrix
additions.
Ignore those for now.
Suppose there weren't any.
I just have to recursively
multiply.
The fact that this actually is
eight times memory transfers of
N over 2 relies on this layout.
Right, I'm assuming that the
arrays that I'm given are given
as contiguous intervals and
memory.
If they aren't,
I mean, if they're scattered
all over memory,
I'm screwed.
There's nothing I can do.
So, but by assuming that I have
this recursive layout,
I know that the recursive
multiplies will always deal with
three consecutive chunks of
memory, one for A,
one for B, one for C,
OK, no matter what I do.
Because these are stored
consecutively,
recursively I have that
invariant.
And I can keep recursing.
And I'm always dealing with
three consecutive chunks of
memory.
That's why I need this layout
is to be able to say this.
OK, Now what does addition
cost?
I'll just give you two
matrices.
They're stored in some linear
order, the same linear order
among the three of them.
Do I care what the linear order
is?
How should I add two matrices,
get the output?
Yeah?
Right, if each of the three
arrays I'm dealing with are
stored in the same order,
I can just scan in parallel
through all three of them and
just add corresponding elements,
and output it to the third.
So, I don't care what the order
is, as long as it's consistent
and I get N^2 over B.
I'll ignore plus one here.
That's just looking at the
entire matrix.
So, there we go:
another recurrence.
We've seen this with N^2,
and we just got N^3.
But, it turns out now we get
something cooler if we use the
right base case.
So now we get to the base case,
ah, the tricky part.
So, any suggestions what base
case I should use?
The block size,
good suggestion.
So, if we have something of
size order B,
we know that takes a constant
number of memory transfers.
It turns out that's not enough.
That won't solve it here.
But good guess.
In this case,
it's not the right answer.
I'll give you some intuition
why.
We are trying to improve on N^3
over B.
If you were just trying to get
it divided by B,
this is a great base case.
But here, we know that just the
improvement afforded by the
block size is not enough.
We have to somehow use the fact
that the cache is big.
It's M, so however big M is,
it's that big.
OK, so if we want to get some
improvement on this,
we've got to have M in the
formula somewhere,
and there's no M's yet.
So, it's got to involve M.
What's that?
MT of M over B?
That would work,
but MT of M is also OK,
I mean, some constant times M,
let's say.
I want to make this constant
small enough so that the entire
problem fits in cache.
So, it's like one third.
I think it's actually,
oh wait, is it the square root
of M actually?
Right, this is an N by N
matrix.
So, it should be C times the
square root of M.
Sorry.
So, the square root of M by
square root of M matrix has M
entries.
If I make C like one third or
something, then I can fit all
three matrices in memory.
Actually, one over square root
of three would do,
but who cares?
So, for some constant,
C, now everything fits in
memory.
How many memory transfers does
it take?
One?
It's a bit too small,
because I do have to read the
problem in.
And now, I mean,
here was one because there's
only one block to read.
Now how many blocks are there
to read?
Constants?
No.
B?
M over B, good.
Get it right eventually.
That's the great thing about
thinking with an oracle.
You can just keep guessing.
M over B because we have cache
size M.
There are M over B blocks in
that cache to read each one,
OK?
This is maybe,
you forgot what M was because
we haven't used it for a long
time.
But M is the number of elements
in cache.
This is the number of blocks in
cache.
OK, some of was saying B,
and it's reasonable to assume
that M over B is about B.
That's like a square cache,
but in general,
we don't make that assumption.
OK, where are we?
We're hopefully done,
just about, good,
because we have three minutes.
So, that's our base case.
I have a square root here;
I just forgot it.
Now we just have to solve it.
Now, this is an easier
recurrence, right?
I don't want to use the master
method, because master method is
not going to handle these B's
and M's, and these crazy base
cases.
OK, master method would prove
N^3.
Great.
Master method doesn't really
think about these kinds of
cases.
But with regression trees,
if you remember way back to the
proof of the master method,
just look at the recursion tree
as geometric up or down where
everything is equal,
and then you just add them up,
every level.
The point is that this is a
nice recurrence.
All of the sub problems are the
same size, and that analysis
always works,
I say, when everything has the
same size, all the children.
So, here's the recursion tree.
We have N^2 over B at the top.
We split into eight subproblems
where each one,
the cost is one half N^2 over
B.
I'm not going to write them
all.
There they are.
You add them up.
How much do you get?
Well, there's eight of them.
Eight times a half is two.
Four.
[LAUGHTER] Thanks.
Four, right?
OK, I'm bad at arithmetic.
I probably already said it,
but there are three kinds of
mathematicians,
those who can add,
and those who can't.
OK, why am I looking at this?
It's obvious.
OK, so we keep going.
This looks geometrically
increasing.
Right?
You just know in your heart
that if you work out the first
two levels, you can tell whether
it's geometrically increasing,
decreasing, or they're all
equal, or something else.
And then you better think.
But I see this as geometrically
increasing.
It will indeed be like 16 at
the next level,
I guess.
OK, it should be.
So, it's increasing.
That means the leaves matter.
So, let's work out the leaves.
And, this is where we use our
base case.
So, we have a problem of size
square root of M.
And so, yeah,
you have a question?
Oh, indeed.
I knew there was something.
I knew it was supposed to be
two out here.
Thanks.
This is why you're here.
It's actually N over two
squared over B.
Thanks.
I'm substituting N over 2 into
this.
OK, so this is actually N^2
over 4 B.
So, I get two,
because there are eight times
one over four.
OK, I wasn't that far off then.
It's still geometrically
increasing, still the case,
OK?
But now, it actually doesn't
matter.
Whatever the cost is,
as long as it's bigger than
one, great.
Now we look at the leaves.
The leaves are root M by root
M.
I substitute root M into this:
I get M over B with some
constants.
Who cares?
So, each leaf is M over B,
OK, lots of them.
How many are there?
This is the only,
deal with recursion trees,
counting the number of leaves
is always the annoying part.
Oh boy, well,
we start with an N by N matrix.
We stop when we get down to
root N by root N matrix.
So, that sounds like something.
Oh boy, I'm cheating here.
Really?
That many?
It sounds plausible.
OK, the claim is,
and I'll cheat.
So I'm going to use the oracle
here, and we'll figure out why
this is the case.
N over root N^3 leaves,
hey what?
I think here,
it's hard to see the tree.
But it's easy to see in the
matrix.
Let's enter the matrix.
We have our big matrix.
We divided in half.
We recursively divide in half.
You get the idea,
OK?
Now, at some point these
sectors, let's say one of these
sectors, and each of these
sectors, fits in cache.
And three of them fit in cache.
So, that's when we stop the
recursion in the analysis.
The algorithm goes all the way.
But in the analysis,
let's say we stop at M.
OK, now, how many leaves or
problems are there?
Oh man, this is still not
obvious.
OK, the number of leaf chunks
here is, like,
I mean, the number of these
things is something like N over
root M, right,
the number of chunks.
But, it's a little less clear
because I have so many of these.
But, all right,
so let's just suppose,
now, I think of normal,
boring, matrix multiplication
on chunks of this size.
That's essentially what the
leaves should tell me.
I start with this big problem,
I recurse out to all these
little, tiny,
multiply this by that,
OK, this root M by root M
chunk.
OK, how many operations,
how many multiplies do I do on
those things?
N^3.
But now, N, the size of my
matrix in terms of these little
sub matrices,
is N over root M.
So, it should be N over root
M^3 subproblems of this size.
If you work it out,
normally we go down to things
of constant size and we get
exactly N^3 of them.
Now we are stopping at this
short point in saying,
well, it's however many there
are, cubed.
OK, this is a bit of hand
waving.
You could work it out with the
recurrence on the number of
leaves.
But there it is.
So, the total here is N over,
let's work it out.
N^3 over M to the three halves,
that's this number of leaves,
times the cost at each leaf,
which is M over B.
So, some of the N's cancel,
and we get N^3 over B root M,
which is a root M factor better
than N^3 over B.
It's actually quite a lot,
the square root of the cache
size.
That is optimal.
The best two level matrix
multiplication algorithm is N^3
over B root M memory transfers.
Pretty amazing,
and I'm over time.
You can generalize this into
all sorts of great things,
but the bottom line is this is
a great way to do matrix
multiplication as a recursion.
We'll see more recursion for
cache oblivious algorithms on
Wednesday.